[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bel et bien en sologne attend sur
l'allumé
[Musique]
dragage des plaintes et plus ce
spectacle c'est le désespoir de
sébastien camus garde chasse en sologne
la propriété où il travaille est
encerclée par les grillages de son
voisin patron d'une grande entreprise
qui possède un territoire de chasse de
2000 hectares entièrement clos de sorte
que les animaux sauvages ne puisse pas à
s'en échapper
sur jazz vous pouvez avoir 300 animaux
de tué au même endroit et qu'elle a
tellement que il à côté ils font un trou
à la pelleteuse il enterre tout est
terminé et c'est pas ça et de la chasse
de la chasse c'est de prélever un animal
ou deux et surtout de s'en nourrir
la chasse en enclos un sujet brûlant qui
révoltent autant les défenseurs des
animaux qu'une grande partie des
chasseurs ulrich baudin et de cela il y
a quelques années il a participé à une
chasse commerciale
j'ai vu officier du chasseur on leur dit
vous tirez pas la bête de tête moi
j'étais dans ma manche l2 battu et j'ai
vu les sangliers sortir et le chasseur
la première chose qu'elle a fait boum
rap il a tiré la bête de tête donc c'est
une mère non respectueux ulrich bodin
n'est jamais retourné dans un enclos
l'association one voice qui milite pour
les droits des animaux
infiltré plusieurs chasses commerciales
en parc fermé
qu'y at il de plus cruel et quelque part
de plus pervers que
d'élever ces animaux de les appâter de
les apprivoiser pour pouvoir faire un
carton derrière on se demande parfois
pourquoi ils font cela parce que on peut
dire la chasse on va après se retrouver
entre amis mais là ça nous alors être
avec son chien mais là ça n'est pas du
tout le cas il y a des miradors alignés
et on tire en tire on tire on tire en se
moquant totalement du fait qu'on n'ait
pu blesser un animal laisser des
semaines entières agoniser et puis qui
va finir à la ben c'est du pur business
c'est du pur business qu'on ne nous dise
pas que c'est de l'écologie les
grillages ce n'est pas écologique du
tout
élever des animaux sauvages qui ne sont
plus sauvage ce n'est pas écologique et
qu'on ne nous dise pas qu'on aime la
nature
les animaux enfermés et nourris se
reproduise en favorisant la
consanguinité et la surpopulation il
laboure des sols ou disparaît la
biodiversité ce qu'a constaté sébastien
camus en sologne
normalement dans un parc de chasse on
doit pas avoir plus d'un an gül à
l'hectare qu'est ce qu'un anglais à 112
est annulé un choix et un anglais un
service et en anglais voilà quand on
voit ça on peut pas me dire qui à moins
d'un millier d'hectares ce n'est pas
possible c'est ravagé cellulaire
la chasse en enclos se pratiquer toute
l'année en toute légalité
lorsque la densité des passes un animal
pour un hectare la réglementation est
celle d'un élevage chasse et devient
alors interdit
faire respecter la loi c'est le rôle des
policiers de l'osce b l'office français
de la biodiversité
aujourd'hui sur un département on est
quinze ses agents office france et
l'administrateur on peut pas être
partout donc là on a un réseau de
partenaires qui vont nous dire et qui
vont nous appelons en disant voilà il se
passe ça est ce que c'est normal est-ce
que c'est pas normal est-ce que c'est
une infraction est-ce que vous pouvez
aller vérifier intervenir un manque
d'effectifs qui se double de contraintes
juridiques
il faut qu'on ait des éléments à charge
il faut qu'on ait l'assentiment de la
personne et que les choses se fassent en
présence de la personne où il faut qu'on
ait une autorisation du juge des
libertés pour pouvoir pénétrer dans ces
structures
de fait les condamnations restent rares
en mai dernier suite à une enquête de
l'olaf b l'homme d'affaires benjamin
tranchant a été condamné par le tribunal
de montargis pour prélèvement de gibier
dans le milieu naturel sans autorisation
décision dont il a fait appel
régulièrement mise en cause par les
opposants à la chasse en enclos il est
le seul à accepter de s'exprimer sur ce
sujet
je me cache pas dans mon petit doigt
donc je vais pas acheter ma tranquillité
et laisser dire tout et n'importe quoi
ça fait des années malheureusement que
c'est une calomnie permanente qu'on
entend qu'on enterre le jb je dis pas
que ça existe pas qu'on enterre si que
c'est un ball-trap cynégétique on roule
sur le maïs que les propriétés sont
dégradées par qui vient de voir
pour justifier l'achat son enclos les
propriétaires évoque principalement les
risques d'intrusion sur le terrain les
policiers de los fb qui contrôle les
grillages constate des dispositifs
parfois dangereux pour les animaux
certains individus vont être tenté de
percer par dessus parce que deux mais
globalement la majorité des animaux ne
franchirons pas et toujours des
exceptions et la l'exception bel animal
en fait ils risquent de se mutiler sur
ce genre de barbelés donc c'est un
dispositif qui n'apporte pas grand chose
si ce n'est que ça peut effectivement
blessé très dangereusement les animaux
qui guérissent être tentés de franchir
[Musique]
brigitte bardot qui vous adresser ce
matin un message ne l'avons appelée et
elle vous interpelle directement barbara
rempiler à propos de la chasse en enclos
qu'elle qualifie de barbarie écoutons la
[Musique]
régie de bardot sur europe 1 est ce que
vous êtes d'accord c'est une sauvagerie
sans non
chasseurs comme brigitte bardot que
c'est une pratique choquant
choquant mais toujours aucune
interdiction contre la chasse en enclos
pourtant quatre propositions de loi l
air lr em et la france 1 soumises ont
été déposés ou en cours d'examen
la solution c'est tout simplement
d'avoir un pouvoir politique qui
encourage de légiférer sans en passant
outre les lobbies de la chasse nous
avons donc là une dichotomie entre ces
lobbyistes de la chasse professionnels
qui ont porte ouverte à l'elysée et l'on
va dire le l'immense majorité des des
chasseurs et nous avons donc des
lobbyistes qui sont là et qui ne
défendent aucun intérêt autre que les
leurs et ce2 des grands sacs chasseurs
c'est l'explication du député la france
insoumise auteur d'une des propositions
de loi
retour à chaumont-sur-tharonne en
sologne chez benjamin tranchant
l'homme d'affaires dénonce une cabale
contre les grands patrons
je suis pas quelqu'un qui va
je vais monter dans certains nombre de
choses si beaucoup de choses sur le plan
culturel pour ma région
par gens qui sont très heureux de
m'avoir sur dans le secteur
j'emploie plus de 100 personnes par
exemple c'est pas les antilles
l'association emploi ne serait ce qu'une
personne ont fait vivre comme une partie
l'économie de la sologne et on fait
plein de choses qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la chasse pour développement
culturel économique de notre région de
ma commune et je suis pas une bête noire
pour le sol ils sont arc boutés sur
leurs acquis ils ne veulent absolument
pas se remettre en question ils ont
tellement l'habitude que les politiques
leur servent la soupe à tour de bras qui
ne se pose pas la question et qu'il ne
voit pas l'évolution sociétale qui est
en train vraiment de s'ancrer en france
c'est en diffusant ce type d'image
tourner dans un parc de chasse
commerciale en sologne de one voice
espère sensibiliser l'ensemble des
citoyens
c'est un système qui a soulevé vraiment
qu'on l'a vu quand on a diffusé les
images on a vu que les français ne
comprenais pas découvrez une pratique de
chasse qui était incompréhensible
scandaleuse pour eux parce que il y à
cette trahison de ces animaux qu'on fait
naître pour les tuer à coup sûr
les filles
si les gens prennent conscience un petit
peu cette pratique quelle conscience de
la
cud de la maltraitance de l'animal une
fois tiré
quelqu'un de sensé ne peut pas être
indifférent
sur rmc le président de la fédération de
chasse willy schraen définit sa
conception de la chasse
je vais t'expliquer ce que t'as pas
compris c'est une pauvre doit avec une
chance qu'on est là pour réguler alors
oui mais c'est ce que je vais faire mais
t'as pas compris ah bah alors si vous
n'êtes pas si oui mais t'as pas qu'on
n'a pas compris que nous c'est une
passion et bien alors a compris qu'on
prend du plaisir dans l'acte de chasse à
tuer ça en fait partie mais non mais tu
n'as pas compris moi je crois mais on va
devenir effectivement les petites mains
de la régulation et que demain on va
dire la charte l'affreuse que tudiants
c'est la vérité mais à monaco - c'est
france mais t'as pas compris
mon métier c'est pas chasseur mais j'en
ai rien à [__] de réguler le principe
même de la chasse c'est de faire de la
régulation c'est à dire éviter la
surpopulation d'une race ou d'une espèce
évitez aussi la consanguinité donc clore
des parcelles que ce soit en parc ou en
enclos pour y faire un rassemblement
d'une espèce expansive ça n'a pas de
sens aucun
le président la fédération de la chasse
a dit que les chasseurs n'étaient pas là
pour réguler oui ça c'est sa façon de
voir les choses c'est pas la mienne moi
je suis pas président de fédération
nationale mais je sais ce que c'est
qu'être à chasseurs éthiques
en novembre dernier en sologne pour la
première fois des élus de toutes
sensibilités politiques des associations
de chasseurs et des écologistes ont
manifesté contre la chasse en enclos ils
pensent qu'ils jouent l'impunité parce
qu'ils ont la fortune eh bien nous nous
allons leur expliquer que l'intérêt
général est supérieur à leur fortune et
que s'ils sont les bienvenus en sologne
comme tout le monde est le bienvenu en
sologne ça n'est pas pour y faire
n'importe quoi les libertés un moment il
faut arrêter de souvent une minorité va
vous imposer à chaque fois de faire ci
ou faire ça parce que je considère que
c'est bien on sait pas bien je pense
qu'à un moment chacun est aussi en droit
de faire et je respecte ceux qui sont
contre je respecte ceux qui mangent pas
de viande mais je respecte aussi ceux
qui ont envie de faire ça et il faut le
faire dans le respect de l'éthique
en attendant le phénomène s'étend plus
de 200 parcs ou enclos dans les
départements en rouge sur la carte
1300 en tout sur le territoire français
selon une étude de la spa ce
l'association de protection des animaux
sauvages près de cent mille animaux sont
détenus en captivité pour être chassés
mais s'agit-il encore de chasse le monde
de la chasse a changé alors je dis pas
qu'ils ont heureusement heureusement il
ya quand même des écarts des chasses qui
se déroule bien qu'ils sont pas tolérés
mais
moi je
je conçois pas pour moi c'est pas des
chasseurs
[Musique]
en france la communauté des chasseurs
est définitivement fracturé en l'absence
de volonté politique
c'est cette communauté toute entière qui
risque d'être mise au ban d'une société
en pleine évolution